pat 40 covers college sports
for sports illustrated he's a senior
writer
i'm hopeful that he's got something
positive to say
because he has been on a negative streak
and pat 40 joins us on the program let's
start with
good news with college football what do
you have for me pat
ah well some practices are underway
some teams are working out actually like
you know hitting each other swapping a
little spit out there
uh we'll see if it actually leads to
real football games between
different institutions of higher
learning not sure we'll get there but by
golly you know we're taking
small steps down baby steps toward a
season how's that
uh how big a news was the connecticut
opt-out
well i mean it was significant first fbs
program to say
we're not playing uh you know that's a
state
that has very restrictive state local
guidelines right now travel restrictions
and they don't have a schedule a full
schedule because they're an independent
team
uh adopted out of a conference so you
know it's hard to know for sure if this
is 100
health and safety related versus the
logistics of the season as an
independent that nobody really cares
about it's not notre dame is an
independence yukon
uh but it's significant that somebody
said no we're not going to do it i
will they won't be the last i don't
believe but they certainly are the first
how big are the opt-outs
so far with the players themselves i
think they're very big
you know a lot of big names going and
there's a lot of speculation and rumor
about that there's going to be a whole
bunch more
uh in the future i think a lot of them
are kind of holding their cards right
now waiting to see if there even is a
season
uh because they don't want to be the one
that steps up and says no i don't want
to play
uh if they don't have to if there's not
going to be a season in the in the fall
then they can just say okay well there's
no season in the fall and they're
certainly not going to play in the
spring but
you know you're seeing some big time
receivers from the big ten
micah parsons the linebacker from the
big ten as well
uh you know there's some big names
opting out with more to come and i do
think it underscores to me
dan first of all yeah i mean they're
taking their
future very seriously as potential nfl
players but
also there's this sensor or this feeling
that you know college football is almost
as much of a risk
as a reward these days for high level
prospects it's like
this is something i have to go through
to get to the nfl
and all i get out of this is potentially
a torn acl as opposed to oh boy i get to
play college football
yeah i don't know where we're headed and
i know that i've had doubts
but they're they're substantiated
they're
they're rooted in actual reality you
know because
two sources have been with me all along
just to say this is going to happen
they're going to try to do this
i'm just trying to look at
the likelihood that this is pulled off
is what
i think the likelihood that we start is
50 50 the likelihood that we finish is
10.90 uh i would say or 20 80.
i just think that there's a lot of of
things that could go wrong and when they
do i think you're going to see
administrators start getting a little
bit squeamish and backing off and i
think
you know if there's going to be a lot of
certain segments
on campuses and in the general public
that are like why are we doing this or
why is
just fbs football doing this when
everybody else is going the other way
and saying we shouldn't play and i think
the answer comes down to
they want the money they need the money
and that answer may not go over very
well with some people
pat 40 covers college athletics for
sports illustrated their senior writer
joining us stan patrick show
also cbssports.com came out with uh
an article yesterday that talked about
the ncaa as far as basketball goes
may try to uh bubble their teams i
i don't know the possibility of doing
something like that obviously you have
less players
and staff that you would have to
quarantine or bubble
the likelihood we could see a college
basketball season that
closely resembles what we have in
orlando is what
well i i think it's going to be tough to
pull off i can understand the theory you
know that maybe you bring
you know half of a conference into
indianapolis if you're the big ten or
something or chicago and you have
you know you play games for around the
clock or
12 hours a day for four days or whatever
and get in as many games as you can
uh something like that i but geez louise
you know
it's tough for much tougher to pull off
when you're talking about
guys that theoretically have classes
even if they're not
in person they still have classes online
uh
do you have uh other logistics from
other
other um sports on campus that you're
trying to take care of as well i
just think it's much harder to do in a
college setting than it would be in a
pro setting and
i just don't think they can pull it off
you had a conference call with the
coaches in the big ten
and that was on monday right and we just
got some details that jim harbaugh kept
interrupting ryan day the ohio state
head coach
and basically accusing him of violating
an ncaa
rule now why isn't the media on that
call
or that we don't have the audio from
that
well the media we're not invited to most
of those calls but what is it what is
the conference call
for the the coaches get together and do
what
i i don't know probably talk about you
know how many positive tests do you guys
have how many do you guys have i
you know that sort of thing but there's
there's calls going on basically
all day every day in some of these
leagues that we hear nothing about
but we certainly heard about this one
it's so good i i said uh earlier in the
show harbaugh
wins the spring he doesn't win in the
fall but he wins this spring he's always
got
you know a trip with his players he's
got something to say here
and then ryan day the ohio state head
coach reportedly told his players
we're going to hang 100 on michigan
when they meet that's at ohio state and
the last time they were there
they could have easily put up 80 on them
that day they put up 63 or whatever
they could have put 80 if they wanted to
oh they could that's the thing it's
again
harbaugh better get his points now
because he's not going to get enough of
them in the fall in october when they
play
so i i hey i i this is what we won out
of ohio state michigan right now it's
just
absolute hatred and yeah if ryan take
and run it up on him
hey look out he just might hey good to
talk to you pat
have a good weekend and let me know if
you ever have any good news to talk
about with college football
i'll try to be positive next week all
right that's pat 40.
covers college athletics for sports
illustrated